Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
WE'RE WITNESSING
A NEW DAWN OF AVIATION.
I WANT TO SHARE THIS
WITH THE WORLD.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
AHH!
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
OHH!
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'LL GIVE YOU $1 MILLION
FOR 20%.
I SMELL GREEDY PEOPLE.
I'M WORTH MORE
THAN THEY ARE.
WELL,
I THINK HE'S FULL OF...
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
I THINK $200,000
WOULD BE A VERY FAIR DEAL.
...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
WE'RE GONNA LICENSE THIS THING
SILLY.
MUSIC TO MY EARS.
WE BELIEVE
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT TEAMS.
THAT'S WHY
WE ARE A GOOD TEAM --
LET HIM TALK,
LET HIM TALK.
NO,
I KNOW THAT THERE IS
A BIG, NASTY, MONEY-BAG
VULTURE...
HERE'S MY SUGGESTION --
SOMEWHERE HERE, BEING QUIET.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT LET'S HEAR
WHAT HE'S GONNA SAY.
IS THERE A CAPACITY
WHERE WE GET
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
PARTICIPATING
IN YOUR OWN UNIQUE WAYS?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS A PREMIUM
VERSION OF A FAVORITE SNACK.
HI. MY NAME IS JORDAN BARROCAS,
AND I'M FROM MIAMI, FLORIDA.
I'M DANIEL FOGELSON,
AND I'M FROM LOS ANGELES.
WE'RE THE FOUNDERS
OF THREE JERKS JERKY
AND ARE HERE SEEKING
A $100,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 15% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
HAVE YOU EVER EATEN JERKY,
ONLY TO FIND YOURSELF ASKING,
"WHAT DID I JUST EAT?"
YES.
EITHER THE JERKY WAS TOUGHER
THAN SHOE LEATHER,
OR FILLED WITH SO MANY CHEMICALS
AND PRESERVATIVES,
YOU COULDN'T PRONOUNCE
MOST OF THE INGREDIENTS?
WELL, THREE JERKS JERKY
HAS CHANGED ALL THAT
BY USING ONLY THE BEST MEAT,
MADE FROM 100% FILET MIGNON.
AHH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
OUR JERKY IS THE MOST TENDER
ON THE PLANET.
LET ME SHOW YOU
WHY THE MEAT MATTERS.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU SEE, AT BEST,
MOST JERKYS ARE MADE
FROM TOP
OR BOTTOM ROUND BEEF.
WHILE THEY'RE ONE OF THE LEANEST
CUTS, IT LACKS FLAVOR,
AND YOU MIGHT LOSE A TOOTH
BITING INTO IT.
AND YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY EATING
A COW'S BUTT.
THE TENDERLOIN,
OR THE FILET MIGNON...
AHH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
...IS THE FINEST STEAK FROM THE
MOST PRECIOUS PART OF THE COW.
LEAN AND SUCCULENT,
THIS TENDER AND BUTTERY BEEF
PUTS ALL OTHER CUTS TO SHAME.
WE HAVE SOME SAMPLES, AND WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU JERKS TO TRY SOME.
Cuban: I'M GLAD HE PUT
THE MACHETE THING DOWN.
OH, WOW.
WOW.
ROBERT, WE GET A WHOLE TRAY.
Herjavec: OH, MY GOSH.
MMM.
THIS SMELLS REALLY GOOD.
I LOVE BEEF JERKY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S SO GOOD.
OH, ROBERT.
Greiner: OH, MY GOD.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN
EAT IT YET.
IT'S AMAZING.
WOW.
I WASN'T KIDDING.
THIS TIME, YOU WEREN'T.
Barrocas:
THE FIRST FLAVOR IS ORIGINAL.
IT'S OUR MOST CLASSIC
AND MOST SAVORY FLAVOR.
THE SECOND IS
MEMPHIS BARBECUE.
BE CAREFUL.
IT HAS A KICK.
AND FINALLY,
CHIPOTLE ADOBO.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
Fogelson: WE'RE EXCITED
TO BRING ON THE THIRD JERK.
WHO'S IT GONNA BE?!
TELL US ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
SO, IN THE PAST 12 MONTHS,
WE'VE HAD $350,000 IN SALES.
OH.
HOW MUCH IS EACH PACKAGE?
$11.99.
WOW. $11.9-- WOW,
YOU ARE A PREMIUM JERK.
WE ARE.
DEFINITELY.
BECAUSE IT'S FILET MIGNON?
THAT'S TWICE THE PRICE OF
AN AVERAGE PACKAGE OF JERK.
WHAT JERK IS BUYING THAT?
[ LAUGHS ]
IT'S TWICE THE PRICE
OF THE GENERIC JERKY,
LIKE
THE GAS STATION JERKY.
RIGHT. I BUY JERKY.
OUR BEST STORE ACTUALLY SELLS
FOR $17.
OH.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE, JORDAN?
$3.20.
CAN YOU
IMPROVE THE PRICING,
OR ARE YOU STUCK
BECAUSE YOU USE FILET?
I'M A LITTLE RESISTANT TO THINK
ABOUT JUST IMPROVING THE PRICE.
WE DO WANT TO SEPARATE OURSELVES
FROM THE COMPETITION.
WE ARE BETTER.
OUR QUALITY IS MUCH BETTER.
AND I FEEL
IF WE PRICE EQUAL TO THEM
THAT WE'RE LOSING A LITTLE BIT
OF OUR INHERENT VALUE.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR
THE MONEY FOR?
THE BIG THING WITH US IS,
WE'RE GETTING KILLED ON
OUR PURCHASING,
BECAUSE WE'RE BUYING EVERYTHING
AT MINIMUMS.
YOUR COST TO GOODS
IS TOO HIGH.
YEAH, IT'S TOO HIGH.
SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO BUY
A DECENT AMOUNT OF INVENTORY
WHEN THE PRICE IS LOW.
HOW LONG CAN YOU STORE IT?
ISN'T THAT A PROBLEM?
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM. WE CAN STORE
IT FOR UP TO A YEAR FROZEN.
O'Leary:
DO YOU USE A CO-PACKER?
WE DO USE A CO-PACKER.
AND DO THEY HAVE CAPACITY
TO QUADRUPLE?
OH, TOTALLY.
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
WE CAN MAKE 50,000 UNITS
PER WEEK.
ARE YOU GETTING PUSHBACK
ON THIS 19% SODIUM?
COMPARED TO
OTHER JERKYS...
YEAH, IT'S LOW.
...IT'S MINIMAL.
WE DON'T USE ANY ARTIFICIAL
PRESERVATIVES, NO NITRATES.
IT'S GLUTEN-FREE, WHICH,
MOST JERKY, SURPRISINGLY,
IS FILLED WITH GLUTEN.
SO, JORDAN, YOU'RE SMALL.
YEAH.
TELL ME HOW
IT BECOMES A LOT BIGGER.
IS IT MORE STORES?
YES. WE NEED TO GET
INTO NATIONAL CHAINS.
BUT THIS IS PROBABLY
GONNA SELL BETTER --
SO, SINCE DAY ONE,
WE'VE DONE ALL OUR SALES
OURSELVES.
HOW BIG IS THE TEAM?
IT'S JUST US,
SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT.
IT'S THE TWO OF US.
THERE'S TWO GUYS, THREE JERKS.
WHERE'S THE THIRD JERK?
SO, WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THE COMPANY, THERE WERE THREE.
YOU WHACKED A JERK?
A LITTLE TOO MUCH
OF A JERK.
A QUICK QUESTION
ABOUT YOUR BRANDING --
JUST SO I UNDERSTAND IT --
THERE'S A BEAR,
AND THERE'S A DONKEY,
AND THERE'S A CHICKEN
OR SOMETHING UNDERNEATH IT.
SO, THAT WAS -- BACK WHEN
THERE WERE THREE OF US,
WE ALL CHOSE ANIMALS
THAT WERE REPRESENTATIVE
OF OUR PERSONALITIES.
SO YOU'RE THE BEAR.
I'M THE BEAR.
HE'S THE WISEASS.
YOU'RE THE DONKEY.
AND THE GUY THAT GOT WHACKED
IS THE CHICKEN?
THE CHICKEN -- SOMETIMES
WE CALLED HIM A COCK.
[ BOTH LAUGHING ]
WOW!
O'Leary: I LIKE IT.
IT'S A FLYER, BECAUSE
THE JERKY BUSINESS IS HUGE,
AND IT'S DOMINATED BY --
BUT IT'S ALSO
INCREDIBLY COMPETITIVE.
THERE'S A LOT OF
SMALL MANUFACTURERS
THAT DO $50,000 TO $100,000
IN SALES
THAT CALL THEMSELVES
PREMIUM.
BUT WE'RE THE ONLY ONES
USING FILET MIGNON.
YEAH, BUT THERE'S NO REASON
THEY CAN'T DO IT EITHER.
LOOK, I LIKE YOU GUYS.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
IT'S A FLYER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000.
I WANT TO BE A THIRD PARTNER.
I WANT 33%.
SO, $100,000.
YOU ASKED FOR $100,000.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000,
AND I WANT 33%.
I WANT TO BE THE THIRD -- I WANT
TO BE THE SHARK, NOT THE JERK.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
REASONABLE OFFER HE'S EVER MADE.
UM, YOU KNOW,
MY RESPONSE TO THAT
WOULD BE JUST BASED
ON OUR VALUATION.
I DON'T THINK
YOUR VALUATION'S CRAZY.
I JUST KNOW WHAT I'M WORTH.
I LIKE YOU GUYS.
YOU KNOW I'M A MEMBER
OF THE CHEVALIER DU TASTEVIN.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND YOU'RE A CONNOISSEUR
OF THE FROMAGE.
I ONLY DO QUALITY.
AND THEY SERVE JERKY.
I WILL DRINK THIS
WITH A GLASS OF BURGUNDY
'CAUSE IT'S VERY GOOD.
Cuban: GUYS,
I LOVE YOUR BUSINESS.
I LOVE BEEF JERKY.
I AM AN AFICIONADO.
I MEAN,
YOU NAME IT, I'VE TRIED IT.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS, THE JERKY
MARKET IS BRUTALLY COMPETITIVE.
YOU'RE JUST IN
THE FIRST INNING.
THE STRUGGLE
IS JUST BEGINNING.
I'M JUST NOT READY
TO TAKE THAT JOURNEY,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
BUT I WILL BE A CUSTOMER.
I THINK YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF
THINGS REALLY WELL.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
A GRIND,
BUT I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT.
AND I LOVE BEEF JERKY.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 20%.
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
THANK YOU.
GUYS, I'M A JERKOLOGIST.
[ LAUGHS ]
MY MOTHER USED TO SAY
THERE'S TWO THINGS --
YOU CAN NEVER HAVE
TOO MUCH
HOT SAUCE OR BEEF JERKY
IN THE HOUSE.
YEAH.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
BUT I LIKE THIS.
I WORK WITH
SOME OF THE BIG DISTRIBUTORS.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $100,000
FOR 20%.
THANK YOU.
AND I'LL MAKE IT INTERESTING.
OH!
I'M GONNA DO THE $100,000,
ALSO FOR 20%.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN, I THINK I'M WORTH MORE
THAN THE AVERAGE SHARK.
I'M MR. WONDERFUL.
I'VE GOT TO BE PAID
A MR. WONDERFUL PREMIUM.
Herjavec: WELL, JORDAN, I THINK
KEVIN DOES SPEAK THE TRUTH.
HE IS A BIGGER JERK
THAN US.
[ LAUGHS ]
LOOK, I'LL GIVE YOU
A LITTLE MORE CASH,
'CAUSE I REALLY WANT
TO BE PART OF YOU GUYS.
HOW MUCH CASH
ARE YOU PUTTING OUT?
I'LL PUT UP $125,000
FOR MY 33%.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT I GOT TO HAVE ENOUGH OF IT
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I'M NOT AFRAID
OF THE EQUITY.
I DON'T MIND
BEING EQUAL PARTNERS.
YEAH.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER MATCHING
THEIR VALUATION?
I BUMPED IT TO $125,000.
THE TROUBLE IS,
I ACTUALLY THINK IN THIS DEAL --
AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO BE ARROGANT.
I'M JUST
SPEAKING THE TRUTH --
THAT I'M WORTH MORE
THAN THEY ARE.
WELL,
I THINK HE'S FULL OF...
[ LAUGHS ]
GUYS,
WE ALL HERE CAN HELP YOU.
AND WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
TAKE MINE DOWN TO 17.5%
FOR THE $100,000.
OKAY. SO --
OKAY,
HE'S GOING THE OTHER WAY.
BUT I NEED AN ANSWER.
BUT MY ONE QUESTION TO YOU
WOULD BE,
AT THAT LEVEL OF EQUITY,
DO YOU THINK YOU'LL STILL
BE INCENTIVIZED
TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR BUSINESS
TO THE FULL EXTENT...
WOW.
...THAT ANOTHER SHARK
AT A HIGHER EQUITY LEVEL WOULD?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY'S
EVER ASKED THAT,
AND THAT IS
A VALID QUESTION.
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING FOR
A THIRD.
I BELIEVE SO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IT'S ABOUT HOW MUCH WORK
THE SHARK IS WILLING TO DO.
ABSOLUTELY.
HOW MUCH CASH DO YOU WANT?
I THINK $200,000 WOULD BE
A VERY FAIR DEAL.
TOO RICH, TOO RICH.
TO SHOW YOU I CARE, ALL RIGHT,
I'LL GO TO $150,000.
I WANT TO BE
A THIRD PARTNER.
BUT THAT'S MY TOP OFFER.
OTHERWISE,
TAKE ONE OF THESE SHARKS.
WILL YOU MEET US HALFWAY
AT $175,000?
NO. I'LL DO $150,000
AND YOU GOT A DEAL.
IT SEEMS YOU'RE COUNTERING BACK
JUST TO KEVIN, RIGHT?
YEAH.
IN NO WAY
AM I COUNTERING BACK TO --
I MEAN, IT FEELS TO ME...
LIKE YOU'RE COUNTERING BACK
JUST TO KEVIN.
WHY DON'T WE DO THIS, GUYS?
ONE SECOND.
I'LL MAKE IT MORE INTERESTING
FOR YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $100,000 FOR 15%,
AND THEN I HAVE AN OPTION
TO GRAB ANOTHER 15%
FOR ANOTHER $100,000,
AND THAT DATING PROCESS,
YOU'LL SEE HOW HANDS-ON I AM.
YEAH.
THAT'S A BETTER DEAL
THAN YOU OFFERED.
AND THEN YOU WILL BE AT 30%
FOR $200,000.
WELL, GUYS,
I NEED THAT ANSWER RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE I LOVE
DECISIVE PARTNERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
Narrator:
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
DANIEL AND JORDAN HAVE
FOUR OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR PREMIUM JERKY COMPANY,
THREE JERKS JERKY.
WELL, GUYS,
I NEED THAT ANSWER RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE I LOVE
DECISIVE PARTNERS.
TOTALLY. THE ONE QUESTION
I JUST WANT TO RESPOND WITH
BEFORE GIVING YOU AN ANSWER
IS IF YOU WOULD CONSIDER
PARTNERING WITH ANOTHER SHARK,
IN PARTICULAR LORI.
I WOULD DO THAT DEAL,
DAYMOND.
NO.
BECAUSE THEN WE'RE GONNA GET
CONFUSED ON WHO WORKS ON WHAT.
WELL, JORDAN, I WOULD --
IF YOU WANTED TWO SHARKS,
I WOULD CONSIDER
GOING IN WITH LORI.
I'M IN ON THAT OFFER.
WE'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 15%,
WITH AN OPTION FOR ANOTHER 15%
AT $100,000,
BUT YOU GET TWO SHARKS.
I'VE GONE UP TO $150,000
FOR 33%.
YOU GET THE CASH NOW.
YOU'VE GOT
TO MAKE THE DECISION.
WE APPRECIATE
YOUR GUYS' OFFERS...
...AND WE'RE GONNA GO
WITH DAYMOND.
AH! YES.
[ LAUGHS ]
I LOVE BEING A JERK!
BRING IT IN HERE.
OOH! THERE YOU GO.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
Fogelson: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ALL.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE.
YEAH!
THANK YOU.
[ CHUCKLES ]
MAKING A DEAL WITH DAYMOND,
WE FEEL,
IS GONNA BE THE ACCELERATOR
TO OUR BUSINESS AND HELP US GROW
INTO A HUGE JERKY COMPANY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
Narrator:
IN SEASON 6 OF "SHARK TANK,"
LORI GREINER INVESTED
IN THE MINI, STUFFED BAGEL BALL,
BANTAM BAGELS.
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED
IN 25%?
I'LL GIVE YOU 1/3.
I WOULD IF YOU DECIDE RIGHT NOW
WITH ME.
YOU'RE DONE.
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
Narrator: LET'S SEE HOW
BANTAM BAGELS IS DOING NOW.
[ HORN HONKS ]
SINCE "SHARK TANK,"
WE'VE BEEN ROLLING IN DOUGH.
WHEN WE PITCHED ON "SHARK TANK,"
OUR SALES WERE $200,000.
IT'S NOW BEEN EIGHT MONTHS,
AND WE'VE ALREADY DONE
OVER $2.1 MILLION IN SALES.
THAT'S OVER 2 MILLION
BAGEL BALLS SOLD.
WHEN WE MADE OUR DEAL, LORI WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR BRANDING,
AND THAT'S WHERE
BAGEL STUFFINS CAME IN.
THIS WAY,
WHEN A CONSUMER SEES OUR PRODUCT
IN THE GROCERY STORE,
THEY'LL UNDERSTAND RIGHT AWAY
WHAT WE ARE.
WE'RE SO GRATEFUL
FOR ALL OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT "SHARK TANK" HAS GIVEN US,
AND THE DOORS KEEP OPENING.
Greiner:
ARE YOU GUYS EXCITED?
YEAH!
I AM SO EXCITED.
I'M IN NEW YORK TODAY
WITH NICK AND ELYSE
BECAUSE WE JUST CLOSED A DEAL
WITH STARBUCKS.
OH, MY GOSH!
[ GASPS ]
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO,
STARBUCKS AGREED
TO TEST BANTAM BAGELS IN 32
OF THEIR NEW YORK STORES.
THAT SMALL TEST
WAS A SUCCESS.
SO STARTING TODAY,
BANTAM BAGELS ARE AVAILABLE
IN 400 OF THEIR LOCATIONS.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO EXPAND
AT THIS RATE,
WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO BE IN 7,000 STARBUCKS
LOCATIONS NATIONWIDE.
IT REALLY DOESN'T GET
ANY BIGGER THAN THIS.
CHEERS!
TO BANTAM BAGELS.
Elyse: WALKING INTO STARBUCKS
AND SEEING OUR BAGELS
MAKES ME FEEL
LIKE WE'VE MADE IT.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALL.
LORI JUST HELPED US CLOSE
A HUGE DEAL WITH DELTA AIRLINES.
WE'RE GONNA BE
ON ALL FIRST-CLASS FLIGHTS
FLYING OUT OF EVERY
NEW YORK AIRPORT COMING SOON.
YAY!
RAH, RAH, RAH, RAH, RAH!
Elyse:
THIS DEAL WITH STARBUCKS IS
GAME-CHANGING FOR OUR BUSINESS,
BUT IT'S ONLY
THE BEGINNING.
WE ARE NOT STOPPING UNTIL WE
CHANGE THE WAY AMERICA BAGELS.
MY NAME IS BELINDA JASMINE,
AND I LIVE
IN SAND CITY, CALIFORNIA.
I LIKE TO SURF
AND BE OUTDOORS,
AND I HAVE A REALLY ACTIVE
AND HEALTHY LIFESTYLE.
BUT, LIKE MANY WOMEN,
I'VE DEVELOPED ISSUES
WITH MY BODY IMAGE.
A LOT OF TIMES,
WHEN I LOOKED IN THE MIRROR,
I DIDN'T LIKE WHAT I SAW, AND
THAT AFFECTED MY CONFIDENCE.
MY PRODUCT TAUGHT ME IT DOESN'T
MATTER HOW OTHER PEOPLE SEE ME.
WHAT MATTERS IS
HOW I SEE MYSELF.
AND IF I FEEL BEAUTIFUL,
OTHER PEOPLE WILL SEE ME
AS BEAUTIFUL, TOO.
30x68?
YEAH.
I NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
SO I CAN INCREASE PRODUCTION
AND LOWER COSTS.
IF I DON'T GET AN INVESTMENT,
I COULD LOSE EVERYTHING.
MY CAR IS ON COLLATERAL.
I HAVE MY LIFE SAVINGS INTO IT.
AND EVEN MY FAMILY HAS A LOT
OF THEIR SAVINGS INTO IT, TOO,
SO THERE'S A LOT
RIDING ON THIS.
I REALLY HOPE THE SHARKS
CAN SEE MY VISION
AND HELP ME GET MY PRODUCT
IN FRONT OF WOMEN EVERYWHERE.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS BELINDA JASMINE,
AND I'M FROM
SAND CITY, CALIFORNIA.
MY COMPANY IS
THE SKINNY MIRROR.
AND I'M SEEKING $200,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
THE SKINNY MIRROR SETS
A REVOLUTIONARY NEW STANDARD
THAT WILL ENABLE THE USER
TO SEE THEIR TRUE SELF.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU LOOKED IN THE MIRROR,
GRABBED AT YOUR STOMACH,
AND SAID,
"MAN, I REALLY NEED
TO LOSE A FEW POUNDS"?
WHETHER WE ADMIT IT OR NOT,
ALMOST EVERYONE CAN RELATE.
WHAT WE OFTEN FORGET, THOUGH,
IS HOW WE FEEL ABOUT OURSELVES
LARGELY AFFECTS
HOW OTHER PEOPLE SEE US.
THE SKINNY MIRROR DESIGN
OFFERS
A SUBTLE, BELIEVABLE,
SLIMMING REFLECTION
DESIGNED TO HELP YOU FEEL GOOD
ABOUT YOUR BODY.
WE'VE ALL HEARD
THAT CLICHÉ PHRASE
"IF YOU LOOK GOOD,
YOU FEEL GOOD."
WELL, WE REALIZED
IT'S THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
IF YOU FEEL GOOD, YOU
[SNAPS FINGERS] LOOK GOOD.
[ SNAPS FINGERS ]
WHEN YOU LOOK IN THE MIRROR
EVERY DAY
AND YOU LIKE WHAT YOU SEE...
[ CHUCKLES ]
...IT GIVES YOU THE INSPIRATION
TO LOOK AND FEEL YOUR BEST.
SO, WOULD ANY OF YOU LIKE TO
COME TRY OUT THE SKINNY MIRROR?
BOY, DO I NEED THAT.
I WILL.
I WANT TO SEE THE COMPARISON.
LADIES FIRST.
GO AHEAD AND TRY IT OUT.
OOH, I LIKE THIS MIRROR.
ALL RIGHT, DAYMOND. COME VIEW.
WHAT DID YOU THINK, LORI?
I WANT TO SEE --
I LOOK SKINNIER.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
YOUR HEAD GOT SMALLER.
WOW.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
Greiner: OH, WOW.
Herjavec: WOW!
VERY NICE.
SO NOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CARRY THAT MIRROR
EVERYWHERE YOU GO.
Greiner: YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, WOW.
BELINDA, ON DAYMOND
IT MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE,
BUT ON LORI,
NOT TO SUCK UP TO HER,
IT DIDN'T MAKE
THAT BIG A DIFFERENCE.
IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S FARTHER BACK.
YEAH. USUALLY,
THE IDEAL PLACE TO STAND
IS ABOUT 3 TO FIVE 5 FEET,
SO --
YOU KNOW, IT'S FUNNY,
'CAUSE A LOT OF WOMEN
SAY THAT TO DAYMOND --
THE FARTHER BACK HE IS,
THE BETTER HE LOOKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BELINDA,
IT'S SUPPORTING A FALSEHOOD,
BECAUSE THE REAL MOTIVATION TO
SLIM DOWN IS TO LOOK AT REALITY,
DEAL WITH THE TRUTH
EVERY DAY,
AND FINALLY GET AROUND
TO THE IDEA THAT LOSING
WEIGHT'S HARD WORK.
AND THEN WHEN YOU SEE
THE RESULTS, THE REAL RESULTS,
YOU'RE VERY MOTIVATED
TO MAINTAIN IT.
THIS IS A FALSEHOOD.
THIS IS A LIE TO SOMEBODY.
SO, LET ME ASK YOU THIS --
WHEN YOU ROLLED OUT OF BED
THIS MORNING,
IS THAT
WHAT YOU LOOKED LIKE?
PRETTY MUCH.
YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, LET'S NOT DEBATE
WHETHER IT'S GOOD OR BAD.
HOW MANY MIRRORS
HAVE YOU SOLD?
WE'VE SOLD ABOUT 350 UNITS,
AND --
FOR HOW MUCH?
A TOTAL -- TOTAL OF $85,000.
IS IT ALL
CLOTHING STORES?
YES,
AND HOTELS, ACTUALLY.
OH,
SO IT'S NOT CONSUMERS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S A FALSEHOOD
BASED ON THE PREMISE
A RETAILER CAN SELL A DRESS
BECAUSE IT LOOKS BETTER
ON SOMEBODY.
YOU'RE BASICALLY PUTTING
A MIRROR INTO A RETAIL STORE
WHERE A WOMAN,
A RUBENESQUE WOMAN, PERHAPS,
WOULD PUT ON A DRESS AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN FLATTER HERSELF
BY THE FACT
A FALSEHOOD'S BEING PORTRAYED.
UNTIL SHE GETS HOME
AND PUTS IT ON.
LET ME TELL YOU THIS --
WE HAD A MARKET STUDY DONE
IN SWEDEN LAST YEAR.
THE FINDINGS THAT
CAME OUT OF THE SURVEY -- ONE.
THE WOMEN WHO WERE USING
THE SKINNY MIRROR
BOUGHT ALMOST 20%
MORE CLOTHES.
WELL,
OF COURSE THEY DID!
WOMEN WERE MORE SATISFIED
WITH THEIR BODIES.
THEIR IDEAL BODY
AND THEIR ACTUAL BODY,
THERE WAS A SMALLER GAP.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AND THERE'S NO TRANSPARENCY.
WAIT, WAIT.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS, BECAUSE --
CAN I JUST FINISH, PLEASE?!
YEAH, GO AHEAD.
NO!
THE FOURTH THING --
WOMEN BELIEVE THEY ARE
TWO TO THREE SIZES LARGER
THAN THEY ARE
IN REAL LIFE.
IS THAT TRUE?
YES.
EVEN I TOOK THE SURVEY,
AND I BELIEVED I WAS
TWO TO THREE SIZES LARGER.
WHEN YOU GO TO
A RETAIL STORE,
DO SOME OF THE STORES
NOT TELL CUSTOMERS AND SOME DO,
OR DO ALL THE STORES
THAT BUY IT
NOT TELL CUSTOMERS
IT'S A SPECIAL MIRROR?
WE'VE HAD BIG-NAME RETAILERS
CALL US FOR A QUOTE
AND ASKED US
TO REMOVE THE LOGO
ON THE BOTTOM-RIGHT CORNER
OF THE MIRROR.
SO, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A $700,000 ORDER.
BUT WHEN I STARTED
THIS COMPANY,
I SAID, "THIS MIRROR WOULD NOT
BE USED TO DECEIVE ANYONE."
AND THAT'S WHY
I TOLD THEM --
BUT IT'S DOING IT
EVERY DAY.
EVEN THOUGH
I COULD HAVE LOST --
YOU'RE SAYING THEY HAVE TO FIND
YOUR LITTLE LOGO DOWN THERE
TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON?
YOU CAN SEE IT. ALL YOU
GOT TO DO IS JUST TAKE A LOOK.
SO, I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
THE CONSUMER MODEL.
THIS IS THE FIRST MODEL.
THIS RETAILS FOR $165.
BUT, BELINDA, YOU DON'T HAVE
A PATENT ON THIS TECHNOLOGY.
IS THE MIRROR ACTUALLY
THAT SKINNY?
ANYBODY CAN ORDER
THAT PIECE OF GLASS.
EXACTLY. IT IS -- BUT IT IS
THE -- IT'S THE INTENTION
AND THE BRANDING
OF THE PRODUCT.
OKAY, I GET IT.
SO YOU'RE TRYING TO TELL ME
THAT YOUR BRAND, SKINNY MIRROR,
IS WORTH $1 MILLION TODAY?
I'VE SEEN THE POTENTIAL.
HAVE YOU TAKEN A LOOK
AT YOURSELF IN THE MIRROR?
[ LAUGHS ]
LOOK, YOU KNOW,
I DEAL IN REALITY.
COME ON. DON'T BE AFRAID.
ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS --
I WILL NOT BE PART --
I WILL NOT BE PART OF THIS SHAM,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
AND LOOK, LOOK.
YOU CAN SMILE
ALL YOU WANT,
BUT THE TRUTH IS,
YOU'RE LYING TO PEOPLE.
I'M OUT, BUT I ALSO
FORBID ANY OTHER SHARK
IN INVESTING IN THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT'S IT.
OKAY, LET ME TELL YOU THIS,
ALL RIGHT?
SO, YOU KNOW HOW THEY SAY
THE CAMERA ADDS 10 POUNDS?
RIGHT.
WHEN YOU LOOK IN
A NORMAL MIRROR,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A FLAT,
TWO-DIMENSIONAL SURFACE.
THE SAME THING HAPPENS.
IT FLATTENS YOU OUT.
WE ARE
THREE-DIMENSIONAL BEINGS.
WE HAVE CURVES.
THIS IS ALL CRAP!
[ LAUGHS ] LET ME FINISH.
YOU'RE LYING TO PEOPLE!
LET ME FINISH.
TELL THE TRUTH!
LOOK,
I CAN SEE BOTH SIDES.
YOU LOOK IN THE MIRROR,
YOU FEEL BETTER, RIGHT?
BUT WHEN THAT MIRROR IS USED TO
INCENT A PURCHASE OF SOME SORT,
THE CHALLENGE THERE
IS FOR THE BRAND,
WHOEVER'S USING THAT
IN THEIR RETAIL STORE
AND SELLING CLOTHES,
IF THAT CUSTOMER FEELS,
"YOU KNOW WHAT? THAT'S NOT
THE WAY I LOOKED IN THE STORE.
WHAT HAPPENED?"
THEN THAT BRAND SUFFERS.
AND IN TERMS
OF AN INVESTMENT,
THAT'S NOT THE TYPE OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT I THINK --
OR RISK THAT I'D LIKE TO TAKE
IN MY INVESTMENTS.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
BELINDA, I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING WRONG WITH THE PRODUCT.
I THINK WOMEN IN GENERAL
AND MANY MEN
LOVE ANYTHING
THAT MAKES THEM LOOK BETTER,
THAT MAKES THEM
FEEL BETTER.
I MEAN,
ISN'T THAT WHAT FAKE HAIR IS?
EXACTLY!
ISN'T THAT WHAT MAKEUP IS?
WHERE IT...FALLS APART IS
IF A CUSTOMER LOOKS AT THAT
AND THEY LOOK GREAT
IN THAT OUTFIT,
AND THEN
THEY TAKE IT HOME,
AND THEY OBVIOUSLY LOOK BAD
OR DIFFERENT,
THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE HAPPY.
UNLESS THEY HAVE
A SKINNY MIRROR AT HOME.
BELINDA,
I'VE GOT SOME ISSUES WITH IT.
I JUST CAN'T
GET AROUND THEM.
I'M OUT.
LET ME PUT THIS BACK.
WHY DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
WHY DID I
BECAUSE I HAD A FAT MIRROR,
AND I HAD NO IDEA IT WAS ADDING
10 POUNDS TO MY REFLECTION.
I STARTED TO DEVELOP
BODY INSECURITIES.
I'M A SURFER.
I'M PRETTY ACTIVE.
I EAT HEALTHY.
I'VE NEVER REALLY HAD
BODY ISSUES BEFORE.
AND SO, ONE DAY, MY FRIEND
CAME OVER, AND SHE SAID,
"THAT MIRROR ADDS 10 POUNDS,"
AND THE LIGHT WENT OFF.
HOW COULD THIS MIRROR AFFECT
HOW I FEEL ABOUT MY BODY
IF I'M SUCH
A HEALTH ADVOCATE?
THAT'S WHY
I NEED YOUR HELP!
I WANT TO SHARE THIS
WITH THE WORLD
AND HELP WOMEN FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THEIR BODIES.
I THINK THAT...
I THINK THAT IT'S DANGEROUS.
IT IS.
BECAUSE I THINK
THAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO ALWAYS NOT BE WHO THEY ARE
AND LIVE AN UNHEALTHY LIFESTYLE,
AND I CAN'T
GET BEHIND THAT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
MOST WOMEN WANT TO BE THINNER
THAN THEY ARE.
MM-HMM.
AND THEY ALWAYS FEEL
THAT THEY LOOK HEAVIER.
THAT'S TRUE.
BUT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING IN A RETAIL PLACE
AND HAVING A MIRROR THAT,
IN KEVIN'S WORDS, DECEIVES YOU
INTO THINKING
THAT YOU LOOK BETTER,
AND THEN
YOU MAKE A PURCHASE.
AND IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T KNOW
THAT THEY'RE IN A STORE
AND THEY'RE LOOKING
IN A SKINNY MIRROR,
THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR ME.
I HAVE TO BE OUT.
THANK YOU, BELINDA.
THAT WAS FINE. THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, BELINDA.
OKAY.
SHE WAS VERY POSITIVE.
SHE HAD AN AMAZING ATTITUDE.
YEAH.
SHE DID TAKE A LOT.
THE SKINNY MIRROR
IS ALL ABOUT
MAKING PEOPLE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
THE INTENTION
FOR THE RETAILERS TO BUY THEM
IS SO THAT
THEIR CUSTOMERS FEEL GOOD,
NOT TO DECEIVE THEM.
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A PRODUCT
THAT THE ENTREPRENEURS
HOPE WILL BECOME A POPULAR
HALLOWEEN TRADITION.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ROB BOULEY.
AND I'M HIS SISTER-IN-LAW,
LAURA RILEY.
Both: AND WE ARE SWITCH WITCH
FROM SALEM, MASSACHUSETTS!
MM-HMM.
SHARKS, WE ARE SEEKING $55,000
FOR 25% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
FOR PARENTS, THE SCARIEST PART
OF HALLOWEEN IS TOO MUCH CANDY.
SWITCH WITCH IS
A CHILDREN'S BOOK AND DOLL
THAT SOLVES THAT PROBLEM.
AND THE REAL MAGIC IS,
IT'S FUN FOR KIDS!
HEY, GUYS.
HI.
HOW WAS TRICK-OR-TREATING?
ALL RIGHT!
COME ON OVER HERE.
OH, WOW.
LOOK AT ALL OF YOUR CANDY!
WOW!
GO AHEAD, GUYS.
SIT RIGHT DOWN
ON THE END OF THE BED --
RIGHT ON THE END
OF THE BED.
HEY, WE'RE GOING TO READ
THE SWITCH WITCH STORY.
[ JOHN LAUGHS ]
"THE SUN GOES DOWN.
IT'S TIME FOR BED.
GO BRUSH YOUR TEETH,
YOU SLEEPYHEAD.
LEAVE YOUR SWEETS
WITH YOUR SWITCH WITCH FRIEND
WHEN KIND GOODBYES
HAVE ALL BEEN SAID."
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
POUR YOUR CANDY IN THE BUCKET.
SWITCH WITCH IS COMING TONIGHT.
SWITCH WITCH IS COMING.
DUMP IT ALL IN.
[ HERJAVEC LAUGHS ]
ALL RIGHT! WHOO-HOO!
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
OKAY,
LIE DOWN FOR BED, GUYS.
THAT'S THE WAY
THE SWITCH WITCH COMES.
GO AHEAD, LIE RIGHT NOW.
GOODNIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Riley: "WHILE YOU'RE ASLEEP,
THESE WORDS WILL RING.
YOU MIGHT, MIGHT HEAR
YOUR SWITCH WITCH SING.
SWITCH-A-ZAM!
SWITCH-A-ZING!"
OOH!
WOW!
"SWITCH THESE TREATS
FOR A SPECIAL THING!
WHEN MORNING COMES UP
WITH THE SUN..."
GUYS, WAKE UP!
LOOK, LOOK!
LOOK AT THE GIFTS
FOR ALL YOUR CANDY!
"...YOUR GIFT IS THERE,
ALL SET AND DONE.
SOMETHING YOU'LL LOVE,
IT'S SURE TO BE."
[ LAUGHS ]
THREE CHEERS FOR
SUPER SWITCH WITCH FUN!
Bouley: OKAY, GUYS.
WHOO!
THANKS SO MUCH.
GOOD JOB, GUYS.
Cuban: GREAT COSTUMES, GUYS,
All: OH!
OH, THE SHARK WENT DOWN.
DOWN GOES THE SHARK.
Riley:
ALL RIGHT, GOOD JOB, KIDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOD JOB. BYE.
SHARKS, WE KNOW OUR PRODUCT
IS FUN FOR KIDS
AND A PROBLEM SOLVER
FOR PARENTS,
BUT WE NEED YOUR HELP
IN THIS MAGICAL JOURNEY
TO TAKE THE SWITCH WITCH
TO EVERY HOUSEHOLD ACROSS
AMERICA EVERY HALLOWEEN.
SO LET ME GET THIS RIGHT -- YOU
BASICALLY TAKE THE KIDS' CANDY,
AND WHEN THEY WAKE UP,
THEIR CANDY'S GONE.
YOU'RE NOT WORRIED
ABOUT LITIGATION?
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOT WHEN THEY SEE
THE GIFT THEY'VE RECEIVED
FROM THEIR SWITCH WITCH.
SO, THE WAY
THE WHOLE IDEA CAME UP IS...
[ GROWLS ]
...MY KIDS CAME HOME
HALLOWEEN NIGHT, 2013,
AND MY WIFE YELLS TO ME,
"ROB, ROB!
DO WE HAVE ANYTHING
TO GIVE THE KIDS?"
AND I'M LIKE, "WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?"
SHE GOES,
"SWITCH WITCH IS COMING."
I SAID,
"WHO IS THE SWITCH WITCH?"
MY KIDS THREW EVERY OUNCE
OF CANDY THEY HAD
RIGHT UP
ON THE COUNTERTOP.
AND WE OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING FOR THEM.
I ACTUALLY THREW THEM
FIVE BUCKS EACH.
WE TOOK THE CANDY AWAY.
I SAID, "WOW.
WHAT A BRILLIANT IDEA?"
SO, ROB, LET ME
UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT.
YES.
I'M A CHILD.
I GO OUT TRICK-OR-TREATING.
YES, YOU ARE.
[ LAUGHS ] THANK YOU.
I COME HOME WITH MY CANDY.
I DUMP IT, AFTER ALL THAT CANDY
I LOOKED FORWARD TO ALL YEAR,
AND YOU GIVE ME THIS
IN EXCHANGE?
[ LAUGHS ]
ACTUALLY,
THE SWITCH WITCH LEAVES.
AND WE DON'T ENCOURAGE KIDS
TO LEAVE ALL OF THEIR CANDY.
OH, THEY ONLY GIVE UP
SOME OF IT?
WELL,
THEY PICK THEIR FAVORITES.
AND IT'S DEPENDENT
ON THE PARENTS.
BUT YOU GIVE THEM JUST THIS,
OR YOU GIVE THEM --
NO. A GIFT.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BASICALLY
HAS TO BE VIRAL ON ITS OWN.
YES.
IT CAN'T BE FORCED.
SO I'M TRYING --
I HAVEN'T HEARD OF IT.
MY KIDS HAVEN'T HEARD OF IT.
NEVER HEARD OF IT.
YEAH,
SO THAT MAKES ME CONCERNED
THAT IT'S NOT VIRAL
AND IT'S BEING FORCED.
Bouley:
WHAT'S AMAZING TO ME IS,
WHEN YAHOO! DID A THING ON US
ON OCTOBER 30th,
OUR SALES JUMPED LIKE CRAZY.
UNFORTUNATELY,
IT WAS OCTOBER 30th.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT ENDED UP,
OUR FACEBOOK ENDED UP
GOING VIRAL.
O'Leary: THE SEASONALITY
OF THIS IDEA IS BRUTAL,
AND THE NEXT DAY AFTER
HALLOWEEN, NO ONE CARES.
THAT'S KIND OF LIKE SAYING,
"NO ONE CARES ABOUT CHRISTMAS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ONE DAY,
AND THEN IT'S OVER."
NO, BUT CHRISTMAS HAS
A HUGE LEAD UP.
YOU SAID THE CONCEPT'S
BEEN AROUND FOR A WHILE.
CORRECT. SO THAT'S --
SO THIS IS PUBLIC DOMAIN.
IT IS.
Cuban: SO, TELL US, BY UNIT,
WHAT IT SELLS FOR,
WHAT IT COSTS YOU,
AND THEN, IN AGGREGATE,
WHAT YOUR SALES ARE.
WE RAN INTO SOME TROUBLE
MANUFACTURING.
WE DID IT ALL
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO WE STARTED AT $29.95.
O'Leary:
IT'S A PLUSH TOY FOR $29.
A LITTLE STEEP, RIGHT?
WITH A BOOK, WITH A BOOK.
AND THE PACKAGING.
AND WE PRICED IT AT
ELF ON THE SHELF,
MENSCH ON A BENCH.
MENSCH ON A BENCH, LORI.
Cuban: BUT WHERE
WERE YOU SELLING THEM,
AND HOW MANY DID
YOU REALLY SELL?
WE SOLD 815 UNITS
IN OUR FIRST SEASON.
52% WAS ONLINE --
AMAZON AND OUR OWN WEBSITE.
WE DID 24% GRASSROOTS.
I WAS OUT KNOCKING ON DOORS.
I WAS IN SALEM, MASSACHUSETTS.
WE WERE AT CRAFT FAIRS.
PEOPLE LOVED THIS PRODUCT,
AND WE SOLD THEM.
SO YOUR SALES
WERE $24,000?
MY SALES WERE $15,700.
PARENTS ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
WITH IT.
WHY DIDN'T IT TAKE OFF?
WE FEEL IT DID.
I MEAN, IT WAS OUR FIRST SEASON.
$15,000 IS NOTHING.
WE DID THOSE SALES IN ONE MONTH
FROM GRASSROOTS.
AND, LOOK, THE MERIT OF REDUCING
SUGAR IS RIGHT ON TREND.
HOWEVER, FOR AN INVESTOR,
THIS IS A NONPROPRIETARY
PLUSH DOLL WITH NO BRAND, RIGHT?
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF IT.
I THINK
YOU SHOULD TAKE THE CUE
FROM WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED
IN SALEM.
IN THE OLD DAYS,
YOU USED TO BURN THE WITCHES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IF I WERE YOU, I'D TAKE THIS
BEHIND THE BARN AND BURN IT,
'CAUSE I THINK IT SUCKS.
I'M OUT.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE MEDIA
THAT YOU HAD, GUYS.
I MEAN, NOBODY EVER
WALKS ONTO THE CARPET
AND SAYS, "PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
OUR PRODUCT," RIGHT?
OF COURSE WE EXPECT YOU TO SAY
AND THINK THAT PEOPLE LOVED IT.
BUT IT DIDN'T SELL.
IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU RAN OUT OF PRODUCT.
THE BIG MEDIA PUSH
WAS THE DAY BEFORE HALLOWEEN.
STILL --
AND MOSTLY, THE ONLY
VENUE FOR PEOPLE TO GET
THE PRODUCT WAS ONLINE.
PEOPLE WERE PAYING
OVERNIGHT SHIPPING,
SO, AFTER THEY SAW
THE YAHOO! ARTICLE
SO THAT THEY COULD GET IT
IN TIME FOR HALLOWEEN.
LAURA, I THINK, YOU KNOW,
FOR ME, I LOVE HALLOWEEN.
I LOVE THE IDEA
OF GETTING FREE CANDY.
SO I CAN'T GET BEHIND IT.
I DON'T SEE IT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, THANK YOU, ROBERT.
WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO BUILD A WHOLE
FAMILY TRADITION AROUND IT.
LOOK, WE DID A DEAL
WITH MENSCH ON A BENCH,
AND THERE'S SO MANY DAYS
OF HANUKKAH.
SAME AS WITH THE ELF THAT'S
ON THE SHELF FOR SO MANY DAYS.
BUT HERE, IT'S LIKE A ONE-NIGHT,
ONE-TIME THING,
WHEREAS BOTH OF THOSE MODELS,
IT'S MANY DAYS AND A LEAD-UP.
THIS IS, TOO.
SO...
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
LORI -- CAN I TRANSLATE
WHAT SHE JUST SAID?
WHAT SHE SAID IS,
YOUR IDEA SUCKS.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WELL, GUYS,
HALLOWEEN IS
A $7.4 BILLION INDUSTRY.
$2.2 BILLION --
YOU JUST BROKE
THE CARDINAL RULE.
WHEN SOMEONE COMES IN
AND TELLS US
THAT IT'S JUST AN ENORMOUS,
MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR INDUSTRY,
SUGGESTING THAT, "OH,
IF WE JUST GET A TINY
AMOUNT, WE'LL BE OKAY."
AND, THEN, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOT BUYING IT.
I THINK YOU'RE INTRODUCING MORE
STRESS THAN YOU'RE SOLVING,
I MEAN,
BECAUSE, AS A PARENT --
AND I HAVE THREE YOUNG KIDS,
TOO, RIGHT?
THEY'RE YOUNG ENOUGH WHERE
WE'RE STILL TAKING THEM AROUND.
WHEN THEY COME BACK,
WE'RE GRABBING THE BAG,
THROWING HALF OF IT AWAY,
LETTING THEM PICK THEIR BEST,
AND GETTING IT DONE.
I JUST THINK, YOU KNOW,
IT'S HARD TO PUSH SOMETHING
FORWARD AND MAKE IT VIRAL.
IT KIND OF HAS TO BE
ORGANICALLY VIRAL.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONE.
FIRST OF ALL,
THIS COULD BE A HOBBY...
...WHICH COULD BE GREAT.
YOU CAN GROW
INTO SOMETHING BIG.
FUBU WAS A HOBBY FOR ME
AT FIRST.
I THINK
IT'S A GREAT HOBBY
THAT MAY GROW
INTO SOMETHING AMAZING.
IT JUST MAY BE TOO SOON FOR ME,
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
Greiner:
THANK YOU. GOOD LUCK.
♪♪
Bouley:
WHEN WE CAME HERE, WE THOUGHT
FOR SURE WE'D GET A DEAL.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THE SHARKS MISSED OUT
ON A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
WE ARE GOING TO BE THE NEXT
MENSCH ON A BENCH
AND ELF ON THE SHELF.
[ MOTOR WHIRRING ]
Narrator: NEXT INTO
THE TANK IS A BUSINESS
THAT ASPIRES TO MAKE UNMANNED
FLIGHT ACCESSIBLE FOR EVERYONE.
♪♪
[ CHUCKLES ]
HI. I'M J.D. CLARIDGE.
AND I'M CHARLES MANNING.
OUR COMPANY IS xCraft.
WE'RE LOOKING
TO SEEK $500,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR
20% OF THE COMPANY.
MUCH LIKE
WHEN THE WRIGHT BROTHERS
FIRST TOOK FLIGHT
IN 1903,
WE ARE WITNESSING
A NEW DAWN OF AVIATION --
THE AGE
OF UNMANNED FLIGHT.
THE X PlusOne
IS A DRONE REDEFINED.
WE'VE COMBINED BOTH THE HOVERING
PRECISION OF A HELICOPTER
AND THE FAST FLIGHT
OF AN AIRCRAFT.
YOU CAN SOAR AT SPEEDS
OF UP TO 60 MILES AN HOUR
AND CLIMB AS HIGH
AS 10,000 FEET.
Cuban: WHOA.
AND YOU CAN
SEAMLESSLY TRANSITION
FROM HIGH SPEED
BACK TO HOVER.
HOW COOL.
xCraft IS
BREAKING BOUNDARIES,
AND WITH YOUR HELP, THE SKY
WILL NO LONGER BE THE LIMIT.
J.D., HOW IS IT DIFFERENT
FROM ALL THE TRADITIONAL DRONES
I CAN BUY TODAY?
SO,
THE FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE
IS THE ABILITY TO TRANSITION
TO FORWARD FLIGHT,
AND IT DOES THAT
WITH A WING.
THIS IS THE WING RIGHT HERE.
THIS MAIN AREA IS THE WING.
OKAY.
SO IT'S HOVERING,
AND THEN, WHEN YOU WANT TO GO
INTO FORWARD FLIGHT,
IT ROTATES LIKE THAT.
Greiner: OH.
OH, I SEE.
NOW IT'S AN AIRPLANE.
WHY DO I CARE, THE FACT THAT
I CAN GO SO MUCH FASTER?
YOU CAN CAPTURE A FAST-MOVING
SUBJECT LIKE A CAR,
OR, YOU KNOW, A MOTORCYCLE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
John:
AND WHAT'S THE RANGE ON THIS?
BECAUSE, IF IT'S GOING
60 MILES AN HOUR,
YOU WOULD HAVE TO PROBABLY BE
IN A HELICOPTER
TO ACCOMPANY IT, RIGHT?
OR YOU CAN BE STATIONARY.
YOU CAN BE STATIONARY,
YEAH.
I MEAN, DEFINITELY,
IT'S MANEUVERABLE,
SO YOU CAN STAY
WITHIN VISUAL RANGE.
BUT ONE KEY PART
IS THAT THIS SYSTEM
ACTUALLY CAN RUN
ENTIRELY AUTONOMOUSLY.
YOU CAN BUILD A FLIGHT PLAN
ON A SOFTWARE SYSTEM ON A PC
AND HAVE IT GO DO THOSE THINGS
AND COME BACK.
CHARLES, AM I ALLOWED
TO CREATE A FLIGHT PLAN
FOR AN UNMANNED DRONE
AND JUST LET IT OUT THERE?
YES, THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION,
ROBERT.
THERE ARE REGULATIONS AND RULES
RIGHT NOW,
AND PRIMARILY, IF YOU'RE FLYING
FOR RECREATIONAL PURPOSES,
YOU NEED TO KEEP IT
WITHIN LINE OF SIGHT,
STAY AWAY FROM
OTHER AIRCRAFT AND AIRPORTS,
AS WELL AS
PERSONAL PROPERTY,
AND THEN, YOU CAN'T FLY
ANY HIGHER THAN 400 FEET.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
IT COSTS US $400
TO MAKE IT.
AND WHAT DO YOU
SELL IT FOR?
IT RETAILS RIGHT NOW
FOR $1,800.
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY?
YEAH. WE'VE GOT $173,000
RIGHT NOW IN PRESALES.
AND THAT'S KICKSTARTER,
THEN?
YES.
KICKSTARTER WAS $143,000,
AND THEN WE'VE DONE ABOUT
$30,000 SINCE ON OUR WEBSITE.
GUYS, WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
ARE YOU ENGINEERS OR --
YEAH, SO, I HAVE WORKED -- I'M
AN AEROSPACE ENGINEER BY TRADE.
I STARTED AT A SCHOOL
AND WORKED AT ORACLE
AND HAVE BEEN IN SOFTWARE
MY WHOLE HISTORY.
I WAS LOOKING AT SOME DRONES
YESTERDAY, ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE I HAVE A PROPERTY
WITH 36 ACRES,
AND I WANT TO BUY SOMETHING
'CAUSE I'M GETTING A DESIGNATION
OF MANAGED FOREST,
AND ONE OF MY RESPONSIBILITIES
IS TO SCAN IT EVERY YEAR
AND LOOK FOR DISEASED TREES,
SO I'M GONNA BUY A DRONE.
CAN I CONFIGURE THE CAMERA
ON A GYROSCOPE BELOW IT
SO THAT I CAN FILM
FROM BELOW?
'CAUSE I HAVE TO TURN IT INTO
AIRPLANE MODE TO USE THAT CAMERA
THE WAY YOU'VE GOT IT
CONFIGURED.
WE'RE WORKING ON IT
RIGHT NOW
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
HOVER IT INVERTED.
AND...
Herjavec:
OH, THERE'S MORE?
YEAH. [ LAUGHS ]
SO, THIS IS CALLED PhoneDrone.
Cuban: A WHAT?
GREINER: PhoneDrone.
PhoneDrone.
Manning: BINGO.
SO, WE CAN USE
OUR SMARTPHONES
FOR ALL DIFFERENT SORTS
OF THINGS TODAY.
[ LAUGHS ] THAT'S GREAT.
BUT NEVER HAVE WE BEEN ABLE TO
ALLOW OUR SMARTPHONES TO FLY...
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
...UNTIL NOW.
I LOVE THIS STUFF.
AND WE HAVE A LITTLE VIDEO
THAT WE CAN SHOW YOU.
SURE.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT.
OH, MY GOD.
OH. THAT IS SO COOL.
NOW, DO YOU USE
THE SENSORS IN THE PHONE
TO DO THE BALANCE
AND EVERYTHING?
EXACTLY.
WE DO, SO YEAH.
SMARTPHONES TODAY HAVE, YOU
KNOW, GYROS AND ACCELEROMETERS.
THEY'VE GOT GPS.
THEY'VE GOT -- A LOT OF THEM
HAVE VERY DECENT CAMERAS.
SO REALLY, THAT'S ALL THE
EXPENSIVE COMPONENTS IN A DRONE.
SO WE'VE LEVERAGED THEM,
BASICALLY TURNED A SMARTPHONE
INTO A DRONE.
HOW MUCH DOES THIS ONE
COST TO MAKE,
AND HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
THIS IS NOT CURRENTLY
FOR SALE.
THIS IS IN DEVELOPMENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
IT WILL COST?
WE'RE LOOKING AT AROUND
A PRICE POINT RETAIL OF $300.
PROBABLY LESS THAN $100
TO MAKE.
J.D., ANSWER THIS FOR ME.
WHERE IS THE SECRET SAUCE
IN YOUR COMPANY?
LIKE, TELL ME WHAT
SOMEBODY CAN'T KNOCK OFF.
Manning:
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE I.P.
BEHIND THE DESIGNS.
THE I.P. BEHIND THIS DESIGN
IS UNIQUE.
THE I.P. BEHIND THIS
DESIGN IS UNIQUE AND,
ALSO, PATENT-PENDING.
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT
THERE IS COMPLETELY OPPORTUNITY
AROUND THE DESIGNS.
WE'RE GONNA LICENSE THIS THING
SILLY.
MUSIC TO MY EARS.
AND DO YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
OR THE CONTACTS
TO GO OUT
AND LICENSE YOURSELF?
WE DO.
SO, THEN, I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHY ARE YOU HERE.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $500,000.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA USE
THAT MONEY FOR?
$250,000
WE WOULD LIKE TO USE
FOR SCALING PRODUCTION
ON THE X PlusOne
TO GET OUR COSTS DOWN.
SO INVENTORY.
AND THEN
THE OTHER $250,000
IS TO FINISH DEVELOPMENT
OF PhoneDrone.
OKAY, WELL, LOOK --
BUT WHAT VALUE ADD
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR?
I'VE HEARD ENOUGH.
YEAH.
I'D LIKE
TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
TO START THINGS OUT HERE,
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS MARKET
QUITE A BIT
FOR THE LAST MONTH,
AND I THINK YOU HAVE
SOME ISSUES AROUND LICENSING
I COULD REALLY
HELP YOU WITH,
BUT I THINK YOU NEED
MORE MONEY.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $750,000
FOR 25%.
AND I WANT --
KEVIN COMING INTO
THE CUBAN ZONE.
NO ROYALTY, NO NOTHING?
NO, NO. THIS IS STRAIGHT EQUITY.
I WAS GONNA ASK THE SAME THING,
DAYMOND.
TURNING OVER A NEW LEAF
THESE DAYS.
O'Leary:
THIS IS A STRAIGHT EQUITY DEAL.
AND THE GRINCH'S HEART
GREW TWO SIZES THAT DAY.
I WANT TO OWN
A LITTLE BIT MORE EQUITY,
SO $750,000 FOR 25%.
WOW, GUYS.
Claridge: WOW. THANK YOU.
HE INCREASED YOUR VALUE
TO 3 MILLION BUCKS.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I SMELL?
I SMELL A NASTY, NASTY SHARK
FIGHT THAT'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
I'LL OFFER YOU $1 MILLION
FOR 25%.
I'LL RAISE MINE TO $1 MILLION,
AS WELL.
I'LL GIVE YOU $1 MILLION
FOR 20%.
WHAT?
BAM!
YEAH.
SO, YOUR VALUE JUST DOUBLED.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT.
I'LL DO THE SAME THING --
$1 MILLION FOR 20%.
WAIT.
SLOW DOWN, SLOW DOWN.
HANG ON. MAYBE WE SHOULD GO
STEP OUT IN THE HALL.
YES, I THINK WE SHOULD ALL GO
[ LAUGHTER ]
BEFORE YOU STEP OUT
IN THE HALL,
WE CONTEMPLATED
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
AND IT'S
A FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY.
WE BELIEVE EVERYTHING
IS ABOUT TEAMWORK.
THAT'S WHY
WE ARE A GOOD TEAM --
LET HIM TALK, LET HIM TALK,
LET HIM TALK.
NO, NO. I WANT TO DO A TEAM DEAL
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE IS
A BIG, NASTY, MONEY-BAG VULTURE
SOMEWHERE HERE, BEING QUIET.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO IF YOU GUYS WANT
TO TALK ABOUT DOING --
WELL, LET'S HEAR
WHAT HE'S GONNA SAY.
Manning:
HERE'S MY SUGGESTION.
IS THERE A CAPACITY
TO DO A SYNDICATE
WHERE WE GET EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU PARTICIPATING
IN YOUR OWN UNIQUE WAYS?
OH,
I'M INTERESTED IN THAT.
Greiner: I'M INTERESTED IN THAT.
FOR WHAT VALUE?
THAT'S VERY RARE
IN THE SHARK TANK.
I NEED ENOUGH EQUITY
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
CHARLES, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
THAT DOLLAR IS
FOR YOU AND THE EQUITY?
SO...
SO, I THINK
A $10 MILLION VALUATION.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
GUYS, HOW DID YOU GO FROM
$2.5 MILLION TO $10 MILLION?
I SMELL GREEDY PEOPLE NOW.
♪♪
Narrator: CHARLES AND J.D.
CAME INTO THE TANK
WITH A $2.5 MILLION VALUATION
FOR THEIR DRONE COMPANY, xCraft.
BUT WITH INTEREST
FROM FOUR SHARKS,
THEY'VE INCREASED THE COMPANY'S
VALUATION TO $10 MILLION.
I SMELL GREEDY PEOPLE NOW.
YOU KNOW, I USED TO TELL
MY DAUGHTERS THIS LITTLE STORY.
WHY DIDN'T THE BABY CRAB WANT
TO SHARE HIS FOOD?
Claridge: MM.
AND THE ANSWER IS BECAUSE
HE WAS JUST A LITTLE SHELLFISH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I CAN'T COUNTER
FOR EVERYBODY HERE,
BUT I DON'T THINK THIS IS
WORTH MORE THAN $6 MILLION,
I DON'T BELIEVE.
SO HE --
THAT'S GOOD FEEDBACK.
HE GOT A CEILING,
AND THAT'S HELPFUL.
I THINK THAT CEILING FOR ME
IS 5%.
I GOT TO HAVE 5% MINIMUM.
THAT'S THE SMALLEST POSITION
I'VE GOT
IN ANYTHING THAT
I'M WORKING HARD ON.
YEAH.
SO, LET ME ASK YOU
A QUALIFYING QUESTION --
IS THERE ANY ONE OF YOU
THAT IS NOT INTERESTED
IN PARTICIPATING?
'CAUSE THAT WILL HELP ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM PRETTY QUICKLY.
I-I'M INTERESTED.
I SEE A LOT OF OIL AND GAS,
SECURITY --
ALL KINDS OF APPLICATIONS
FOR IT -- DEFENSE.
I'M INTERESTED.
WE'RE ALL INTERESTED.
MARK, ARE YOU INTERESTED?
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
MARK'S NOT SAYING.
Manning:
OKAY, THAT'S HELPFUL.
HE HASN'T SAID.
WE'LL SEE.
[ LAUGHS ]
I THINK IT'D BE GOOD
TO CHAT, OKAY?
Claridge: LET'S STEP OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: I JUST WANT YOU GUYS
TO BE CLEAR,
THERE'S A LOT OF
PRIVACY ISSUES.
THIS ISN'T A SLAM DUNK.
Manning:
IT'S YOUR CALL.
I THINK WE SHOULD TRY
TO GET THEM ALL.
AT A $6 MILLION VALUATION
FOR 25%, IF THERE'S FIVE OF US,
SIMPLE MATH, WE EACH HAVE
TO PUT UP $300,000.
MARK?
I DON'T KNOW.
John: WHAT'S YOUR RESERVATION,
MARK?
I DON'T KNOW. I WANT TO HEAR
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY.
Manning:
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE EXCITED.
WE'RE MOSTLY EXCITED ABOUT
DOING SOMETHING TOGETHER.
OKAY. DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO PROPOSE TO US?
WE DO.
YES. WE WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE
$1.5 MILLION,
EACH AT 5% EQUITY,
AND BRING ALL THE SHARKS IN.
YOU'RE WILLING TO GIVE UP
25% OF THE COMPANY.
WE EACH PUT UP $300,000 FOR 5%,
25% TOTAL.
THAT GIVES YOU
A $6 MILLION VALUATION.
I'M OKAY WITH THIS DEAL.
I'M ONE SHARK.
I WOULD DO THAT DEAL.
I'M OKAY WITH THAT DEAL.
I'M OKAY WITH THAT DEAL,
AS WELL.
THAT'S THREE. ROBERT?
THEN I'M IN ON THAT DEAL,
TOO.
MARK...WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU GUYS ARE SMART.
DID ANYBODY ELSE OFFER YOU MONEY
PRIOR TO THIS?
Claridge: FOR SURE.
OKAY.
YEAH.
AND SO,
WHEN SOMEONE'S COME TO YOU,
WHAT WERE THE DISCUSSIONS?
THERE'S REALLY TWO CATEGORIES
OF CONVERSATIONS.
ONE IS STRATEGIC, AND ONE IS
KIND OF PSEUDO-INSTITUTIONAL.
A LOT OF
THE INSTITUTIONAL GUYS
WANT TO KIND OF SHAPE IT LIKE
AN EARLY-STAGE V.C. STRUCTURE,
NOT SOMETHING WE'RE
AS EXCITED ABOUT DOING.
YOU ALL HAVE A LOT MORE
OPERATIONAL-EXECUTION
EXPERIENCE, RESPECTFULLY,
THAN MANY TRADITIONAL
EARLY-STAGE V.C. GUYS,
AND YOU ALSO COVER
A SPECTRUM.
YOU COVER A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT AREAS,
WHICH IS REALLY USEFUL
TO THE BUSINESS,
'CAUSE THAT'S
THE WHOLE MODEL.
Herjavec: CHARLES,
I THINK THAT'S SO SMART.
I DEAL WITH A LOT OF V.C. GUYS,
LIKE WE ALL DO,
AND I GOT TO TELL YOU,
THEY'RE ALL SUPER SMART...
THEY ARE.
...THEY'RE ALL GREAT THEORY,
BUT THEY DON'T GET THEIR HANDS
DIRTY IN RUNNING BUSINESSES.
THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
ALL RIGHT, MARK, ARE YOU IN?
♪♪
THAT WORKS.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE IN.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
Cuban:
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
I'M REALLY EXCITED.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Greiner: GOOD JOB.
Herjavec: GOOD JOB!
Manning: WE SHOULD DO
A SPECIAL PARTY
WHERE WE DO
A LITTLE FLIGHT PARTY.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE GOT A SHARK TANK SYNDICATE.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
I'M EXCITED.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
OWN THIS MARKET.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE THRILLED.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT.
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL-DONE.
Claridge:
I'M JUST AMAZED RIGHT NOW
THAT WE HAVE NOT ONLY GOTTEN
A VALUATION THAT'S GREATER
THAN WHAT WE ASKED,
WE GOT MORE MONEY
THAN WHAT WE ASKED FOR --
THREE TIMES AS MUCH -- AND WE
GOT ALL FIVE SHARKS ON BOARD.
NICE JOB, FELLOW SHARKS.
Cuban: ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
COOL. WE'RE IN
THE DRONE BUSINESS.
THAT IS COOL.